VEGAS IN THE HOME
PLAYERS LAST WEEK WITH COVID AS
WELL.
>> CHICAGO WININCH PIECE TOGETH
SPIN THAT POWER PLAY FOR
THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS.
CENTERS FOR TOEWS, AND HE
SCORES!
PLAY.
HE GETS TO TH COACH
JEREMY CO STREAKING
TOWARDS THE
PLAY.
YOU'LL SEE HIM COMING AT THE
VERY TOP WITHUMP IT IN.
AMADIO LET IT PASS BY FOR PACE
AND DIPS DODOWAY
FROM THE FORTRESS.
THEODORE DOWN LOW FOR
HE'S GOING GET LOST UP  FROM
EICHEL TO THE
HERE'S MARTINEZ.
HASN'T PLAYED MUCH IN HIS RETURN
TOT BY
HUTTON.
AT THE LINE, JONES FOR STROME.
STROME FOR DeBRINCAT.
THEY CONTINUE TO CIRCLE.D IT.
LIKE, IT'S SO EASY FOR HIM, SUCH
PATIENCE.
AS THOMPSON GOES
JANMARK.
ROY.
AT THE LINE PIETRANGELOTIAS JANG
FACE-OFF, YOU JUST ARE PATIENT..
YOU'LL HOLD
DADONOV RIGHT IN THE SLOT, AND
HE SCORES!